[Music]
well that's very it's good to see you
for people who are watching this they
probably don't know that we've we've
exchanged quite a few emails in the past
we've even had some phone calls and so
it's it's kind of nice to have a public
discussion yeah this is exciting so you
might be really excited your book is
when is your book coming out so my book
comes out August 25th and it's called a
cloud of outrageous glue it's put a copy
behind me you know cuz you're supposed
to do that you know you're supposed to
first of all pose in front of a
bookshelf you know to show that you're
widely read and then you're supposed to
like casual your copy of your own book
among the Canon you know you're doing
everything right there you go you're
doing everything right and so are you
done are you finished yeah it's so
here's the crazy thing about the book as
you know it's a book about the great
plague of 1348 so it's a pandemic book
and I just so happened to have like
wrapped it up and put a nice neat little
bow on it in just after the new year
like just in January got through the
last pass of the copy editing handed in
all the artwork and then the pandemic is
so sort of relevant sort of timely I
think we can have some interesting
things to talk about today yeah so how
do you how do you feel like I mean it
must be a weird we always always use the
phrase symbolism happens when you know
you something all these patterns are
kind of coming together in a way that
wasn't planned but ends up looking
almost as if someone playing cos says
maybe you were in on the conspiracy and
from the beginning you know yes so maybe
we can talk about it start with that if
you're interested and I mean I'd like to
get a sense of how in terms of narrative
how you treated the question of the
plague is human relationships and how it
relates to kind of what we're going
through right now
yeah well originally this wasn't the
book that I was
right I was gonna write a book about
about the fluidity of time time and
space the fact that land holds memory
there all these other things that I was
gonna write about these two girls that
could see each other through time so
nobody kissed nobody steal that idea cuz
I'm still gonna write that book
but my publisher because I had written a
historical fiction book when I first
came on with Kanab they wanted to kind
of keep me in a historical fiction vein
for readers and so I kind of went you
know squarely to the medieval part of
the story and you know I've always been
a medieval file I you know like I kind
of cut my teeth on iconography like in
more of an art historical sense than a
faith sense I I'm not Orthodox but um so
it was interesting to me but like I
couldn't settle on a time period I was
gonna I really wanted to write something
from like around the turn of the
millennium like the Hildegard von Bingen
kind of era yeah right there just wasn't
enough documentation but it seemed like
right around the time of the plague all
of this documentation kind of hit you
know and there was just a lot more
wealth of research available you know so
that's kind of how I fell into the time
period and I thought oh wouldn't it be
interesting to write about a girl or
anybody who was like who had these
powers of perception but also was
perceived as kind of a misfit you know
as all this chaos was breaking out you
know like how because like the subject
of saints you know how does somebody
become a saint and then how does
somebody become labeled a heretic well
sometimes that's the same person
sometimes they're a saint one minute and
then they you know get labeled heretic
next and they're being burned at the
stake or sometimes they're considered a
heretic but then after they're burned at
the stake they emerge as a saint you
know so I thought okay well what would
it be like
be that a real person hmm right who's on
the outside who's a misfit and has this
way of seeing the world that isn't like
everybody else doesn't conform as the
world's falling apart yeah so that's
what the book is about and her her kind
of powers of perception really are there
synesthesia so are you familiar with yep
what's yeah so for I guess for those who
don't know it's a kind of crossing over
at the senses neurologically so that
people can see sound as color you know
playing out before them or they can
taste emotion or things like that so
yeah and how do you feel do you feel
like the the way you approach that's a
disease or or the plague time how do you
see it do you see it connected because
the thing about the time with the plague
is we there was a lot of apocalypticism
at the same time obviously it makes
sense you've got half the population
people dying off whole villages you know
being exterminated by this plague and so
you can imagine that there was a lot of
conspiracy and a lot of apocalypticism
going on kind of madness took over some
aspects of European culture not
everywhere some some places remain quite
sane but you know this idea of the image
of the Jews poisoning the well or these
this kind of idea of the stranger who is
the one who brings about the plague so I
don't know if you were able to deal with
those ideas in your book as well this
kind of weird apocalypticism that comes
about yeah yeah definitely I mean that
that plays out in the latter half of the
book when the plague actually hits but
because my first novel was about the
post Holocaust period and I was dealing
with the question of how anti-semitism
arises when it arises and one of the
things that I discovered in the research
for that was that these major
persecutions of the Jews emerge like
clockwork like every 70 to 100 years so
maybe like once a generation there will
be like a major persecution of the Jews
the Holocaust was not the first and
certainly won't be the last it just
happened to be the biggest but
and that's how I discovered you know the
persecution of the Jews during the
plague now in England where my book has
set it's a little bit different because
the Jews have been expelled I can't I
can't remember which king it was I think
it was one of the Edwards who had
expelled them in the 13th century there
wasn't like a tangible Jewish community
but in places you know more in Central
Europe that was really a monstrous thing
that was taking place so but what
emerged in England and in other parts of
Europe was the the movement of the
flagellants like the people who go
through streets you know whipping
themselves and stuff and so that is
something that I felt was important was
was important and was kind of of a peace
with that kind of real thinking yeah and
it's happening now we're seeing
flagellants right now I mean I mean
totally and it's kind of like every
stage of this thing right from the
announcement of the pandemics all the
way through to like yesterday I saw a
video of yesterday today of the mayor of
Minneapolis being hauled before a crowd
yeah and told to defund the police an
idea which is about light in the public
consciousness which is about one week
old so we're gonna like completely
dismantle this whole system in one week
and what was he gonna do you know like
he had to the option was so flagellate
or maybe we'll kill you or flee for your
life yeah you know so yeah it's very
it's a very it's very strange because a
lot of people don't necessarily want to
see or don't understand that there's a
direct connection between what's
happening in terms of the riots and in
terms of the protest and the the kovat
it's related narrative Lee it's related
in terms of of general apocalypticism
right that's what's that that's most of
what's going on the sense
that either the this system is falling
apart it's going to end or that the
system has to end that we will be part
of its dismantling and then there then
what we haven't seen yet but which is
coming and we've seen some hints of it
actually in Chicago there were some
hints of it where it's going to be
people resisting and saying no we don't
want to dismantle this system and we're
going to fight to stop it and so it's
not it's looking it's not looking it's
not looking like a bright like a bright
future no and I was talking to somebody
earlier today and I I said you know this
could kind of go a number of different
ways we could either like we were saying
you know you never know that you're
living in a moment of history until you
look back on it right well everybody's
saying this is a historic moment and I
said well that's certainly possible I
mean two of the options are that we
could either you know find a great
solution and move forward in this like
way of peace and have like a 1964 Civil
Rights Act moment where things get
healed you know at least enough for the
moment to be able to move forward right
or we could break out into open civil
war the third option is the thing Peters
out and we look back and we're like oh
remember that thing that happened yeah
that was weird
you know I mean I don't think so but you
know I think the movement the fact that
the movements whether it's kovat or it's
the race riots that there's that there
global is something that we haven't seen
in our generation yeah yeah we'll see
we'll see how it goes I don't think I
think that because it's also an election
year I don't see this changing at least
for the near future so we're gonna have
to strap on its I had it's a weird visit
at the beginning of the year I said I
tell people this year you guys get ready
for this year because it's going to be
crazy
but I didn't expect all of it I didn't
expect so much tick to come together so
oh my goodness it I feel like I'm living
in a movie I can't believe it you know
well the images of the protestors
wearing masks it really looks like like
a science fiction movie like like like a
post-apocalyptic movie so yeah we are
definitely the story is definitely
ramping up yes and so the thing about
the plague is that it it came there was
a lot of upheaval during the time of the
plague and we don't people don't
remember that so much there was a lot of
peasant revolts and there was a lot of
let's say people from the higher classes
who were being you know killed just
being stopped and stopped on the road
and being killed and there were revolts
like actual you know yeah civil war type
revolts within the peasants after that
during the time of the plague and
especially after after the first wave
right right like the peasants revolt of
1381 and and I think what's interesting
is that um I mean there's just so many
parallels but you know you had in like
1315 you had the Great Famine right and
so the parents of the people the parents
of let's say the young people during the
plague had experienced their own trauma
you know with the Great Famine where
like a significant amount of the
population of Europe died in that
because of I think it was the end of the
Medieval Warm Period so you had this
like climate change event and
catastrophic famine like that Oh an
already kind of weakened population
right and then into that comes the
pandemic and then into that comes the
civil unrest yeah you know and so it's
interesting that you brought up the
revolts - because one of the things that
has been fascinating to me is the degree
to which the plague was responsible for
the birth of the modern world yeah very
much so the Renaissance is a direct
descendant of the plague or a react
- the plague as well because one of the
things that happened during the plague
is that a lot of the institution's also
broke down
you know the Catholic Church
institutions broke down the level of of
learning in the clergy went way down and
so you so you can understand how at the
time of the Renaissance people also
they'd forgotten the 12th century I mean
they forgotten how glorious the 12th
century was and they were like oh no
where where this is it like this is the
Renaissance where we were being born out
of out of his very very dark time which
is mostly the time of the plague mostly
the time ages so he's saying that like
the Renaissance was sort of a
short-sighted
I think so yeah so that like they were
reading reading darkness into the whole
time before then that wasn't there I
think so well I mean the whole idea that
real real darkness of the time before
was more was came later during the
Enlightenment you know right the term
Dark Ages and all this type of
terminology came in but I think there
was already some some sense of that in
the time of the time of the Renaissance
you know because they were also
unearthing all these things from the
from the ground you know they were
taking out all these statues they were
kind of bringing up all this this very
old past and you know and also they were
breaking away from Constantinople you
can see in some of the writings of the
Renaissance artists that they talk about
moving away from the from the like the
eastern way of painting you know that
they were doing it deliberately they
wanted to move away from that type of
painting so there was a lot of things
there was definitely a lot of things
going on but did like if you look at
12th century culture it was so radiant I
mean it was really all the Gothic I mean
is there anything more European than
Gothic architecture and that's all comes
from the 12th century I mean is there
anything more like soaring of for the
human spirit you know even now to walk
into a Gothic cathedral and you feel
your heart just rise to something so
much higher than yourself you know even
just like your eyes being drawn up you
know and you know what came
after that was everything was was an
imitation of that basically until the
Enlightenment and that's no than
everything kind of yeah there's
definitely the new clinical the new
classical move is really a I hate to say
but the neoclassical move was always a
kind of a weird anti Christian move kind
of desire to return to the pagans
returned to the Greeks returned to the
ancients and kind of forget all that
happened all the glory of the you know
of the High Middle Ages I'd say the
artistic accomplishments that were there
so that's I'm definitely speaking I'm
not speaking objectively I'm definitely
speaking from my my side of the artistic
battle well sure and you know I was
actually thinking of you when I've been
listening to the the audiobook of
giorgio vasari z-- lives of the artists
which I haven't touched since high
school
you know APR 10 2015
a completely different set of concerns
from the humanist Renaissance concerns
yeah but he treated it instead as a
primitive right yeah and I think but
it's interesting because we're in a way
where we've reached the end I guess of
this we've kind of come even the modern
the modern period like the the 20th
century period was already a breakdown
of the Renaissance idea and already a
breakdown of the ideals of the
Renaissance and so you can see in modern
artists an inkling let's say and someone
like Kandinsky you can see an inkling of
trying to recover a different type of
artistic language and more algebraic
language and more typifies language and
so I think that right now most people
have the capacity to understand what
iconography is about they they're not as
blinded as they were you know during the
period where it's like I don't think
they could have even imagined what this
was about like what was this stupid art
about but at the same time it acts as a
weird it's funny because it acts as a
myth a lot as a mythological backdrop
for even the Renaissance in in making
the Middle Ages dark and in making them
kind of this dark past that we're moving
out of they ended up making it also a
mythological backdrop out of which they
ended up existing you know just just
like just like if you read if you read
Greek architecture er a Greek myth and
everything to have this sense of this
ancient time you know these this time of
the gods at the time these time of the
Titans or the time before out of which
we are we were not that but we're still
it's kind of like our unconscious past
that we're our imaginary times right and
so you have all the fairy tales all the
folk stories end up looking way more
medieval in their structure the King
right the castle the prince the princess
all of this stuff is although I did
continue into the modern age it really
does have a medieval you know medieval
root the dragon the trolls all the
monsters all of this stuff is definitely
more medieval and it's still there today
I mean all the fantasy is really just
treating the Middle Ages as a as a dream
as a kind of mythological dream world
right right and I'm just gonna plug
something here first of all the fact
that you mentioned Kandinsky who was
also a sinister
barian oh really I didn't know yeah he
was a [ __ ] it makes sense things about
yeah but you know if there's any anybody
watching or listening to this now who's
a fantasy fan I call a cloud of
outrageous blue fantasy adjacent okay so
it is historical fiction yeah its
historical fiction for sure but it does
have this because it deals with
perception and it deals with kind of
magical thinking and it's written in
sort of a magical realist style I think
that you know people who enjoy fantasy
will kind of like find a way into that
but so have you read
I think it's Kazuo Ishiguro is that am i
saying his name right the one who the
man who wrote as it remains of the day
oh my gosh anyway he was gonna be no no
I didn't well he wrote a book that you
should definitely recall the Buried
Giants okay and it is written at the
moment where I think it's probably
supposed to take place in the year maybe
600 okay and it's this kind of
transitional point from when from the
the when the Saxons had come in and sort
of like assimilated right so you have
like this conflict between the Saxons
and the Britons
you know the Britons Bri T ons yeah yeah
and as like Britain culture is kind of
dying out and Saxon culture is rising
right but the cool thing about it is
that first you think you're reading a
book of historical fiction but then
there's a dragon and these like mythical
realities are just kind of taken as
commonplace mm-hmm and they they go to
find this buried giant you know and so
the book really becomes like about the
death of the old world and they're like
the death of dream time the death of
that time before and the emergence of
like what then is modern yea modern
world right what's the right time to
deal with it deal with it because the
way that I talk about the Middle Ages is
also the way that the Celtic past when
it plays for the Saxon invasion because
in the end your king is still going to
be King Arthur you know hundreds and
hundreds of years later your king is
still King Arthur he's still he's still
a Celt none know despite the four he's
still from that world so there's a
sometimes an idea that he's roaming
about that right he's like that he's a
Roman but in that time and so none so
despite the fact that you pushed that
aside you push it into the margins you
know it still remains
as your kind of mythical past yeah yeah
and the burry Jayant is actually a post
Arthurian legend so it has characters
you know some of the knights the r3 and
knights who are like three who are
elderly now and they're dying out you
know and it's set among this backdrop of
like where there's still Roman villas
around right but they're they're ruined
they're crumbling it's fascinating you
would really love this book it's the
sixth century really is one of them for
me one of the most fascinating moments
yes you know when I when I think of a
period of time that I wish I could have
visited that's really that's when yeah I
know yeah yeah I think sometime in the
future I'm gonna wind up writing I think
that a cloud about rageous blue I have
in mind that it would be part of the
trilogy with a modern-day version and
then going all the way back to either
that you know six hundreds time or maybe
to like 600 BC you know like pre Roman
Britain or or maybe Rome Madrid I don't
know but I just I think that what
strikes me about all of this like I get
to England whenever I can it's it's my
happy place and when I'm there I I feel
the memory of the land hmm you know and
part of what interested me about writing
about this time period when it was going
to be this other book was when you go to
a place of worship in England you
quickly discover that it it's always
been a worship site hmm you know before
it was a Christian worship site it was a
pagan worship site you know you'll have
these healing wells
you know these holy wells we're not just
you know a saint is associated with it
but then like a pagan figure is
associated with it as well you know so
they did a good job at integrating their
you know their past but the Romans and
the Greeks did too but then they just
imposed it
everybody else like the Romans also did
a really good job at integrating their
past and then they they tried to impose
it on yeah it's pride imposing on on
England which is really insane it's so
far removed it's like why you tried to
impose this weird Roman thing on us I
don't know yeah yeah totally so so I'm
interested to know you're more of your
thoughts on okay so if we're if we look
at the plague as sort of like the birth
of the modern world and then this
backdrop of you know what they labeled
as the Dark Ages you know the time
before and then I mean gosh you can just
trace a straight a completely straight
line from plague to Renaissance to
enlightenment to you know 20th century
even 20th century genocide you know
history the Industrial Revolution
scientific revolution and all of that
right even the birth of modern medicine
from the plague
you know are you familiar with Gita
Sholay ACK he so he was I think the
Pope's physician in Avignon and he
contracted the plague and he
experimented on himself hmm try to find
you know remedies for it obviously using
like you know gallons poor humors you
know Hugh Merrick method but he he
survived right and the whole time he
documented his experiments right I mean
that's the birth of modern medicine in
my opinion you know that like
application of experiment and scientific
method right so with all that being said
that's straight line being traced do you
think that we're like in another cycle
of that and we're on that cycle do you
think we are like you mentioned that in
Chicago like this is playing out exactly
how you well no I I just said I when I
talked about Chicago which is good I saw
an article about seeing some seeing
because until now we've seen the
protests and the we've seen the riots
and then I there was also some articles
about you know young men with baseball
bats just hanging out trying to wanting
to stop people from coming into the
neighborhoods so I was like if that
stuff starts to happen which seems
inevitable at this point then it's just
going to become like you said just can
become a low-key civil war at first and
then when the when the military the
National Guard the police are feel
forced to take sides and it's going to
get really messy so messy so it's a
different it's a very different
situation in that in that sense is
different from at the time of the plague
in the time of the plague you really I
mean because of the plague and because
of the social chaos then all of a sudden
the serfs had flexibility right and they
also because the the so many people died
then there the value of their work went
up dramatically and so there it's one of
the times in ancient you know in the
ancient times when the lower-class had
the most money because they were so in
much in demand you know all the know all
the nobles were looking for serfs to
work on their land and so they tried to
keep them on the land because the serfs
were bound to the land they just
couldn't because it was like we are what
are you gonna do you know it's like the
world is empty of people right you know
so it was it was a week and it's
interesting because it's actually I
talked about this in a recent video we
tend to think that revolts happen when
people are desperate and that is
actually I don't think that's actually
totally true
I think revolts happen actually when
when people are a little better off yeah
I mean they have room to to maneuver in
the middle yeah sorry so yeah so after
the plague
the peasants had more power than they
that they had had in the last few
centuries and that's what gave them the
possibility to to revolt at least in
that that situation right because you
you have 40 years between the plague and
the peasants revolt with 35 years maybe
so it's not in the middle of the plague
where everybody's dropping dead that's
just the fear part that's the that's the
crisis
moment but then when you have some
ability to reflect then comes in the
Racal yeah and also it's it was also it
was also economic because they did have
the possibility all of a sudden right
now they weren't bound anymore the
nobles didn't have the capacity to to
kind of hold them to their land and so
they had freedom movement they were
making more money there was a lot of
land like just veil of a land you can
just take land and do stuff and so then
they didn't want to they just didn't
they wanted to have their own thing they
didn't want to submit any more so which
is totally understandable you know you
can also see why that would happen yeah
yeah I mean this is that's this is a
whole other tangent but like you know I
kind of think I mean with my limited
knowledge I'm not a historian I'm just a
historical fiction writer but it seems
to me like that's the birth of the
individual in Western culture mm-hmm you
know when we when well yeah well the
revolt yeah the revolts like when the
serf becomes untied to the to the
community like to the communal structure
and can branch off on his own you know
go like seek his fortune in the in the
kind of you know and then it's a fairy
tale sense right but then you have like
almost a theology of the individual that
kind of emerges into the modern world
right and the concept of individual
rights or like bargaining for your labor
for your wage you know think about it's
interesting to think about yeah yeah we
have to think about it more it's
possible that it there's definitely
something happening in the late Middle
Ages which seemed to be sparking some of
that you know yeah yeah I'm not saying
it emerged out of nowhere but just that
the conditions were right for that to
kind of come to fruition yeah yeah yes
but it's it's weird to compare the two
to the two now because it's everything
now is happening in real time and it's
okay
press and is so accentuated because on
the one hand the let's say the disease
we had it has nothing to do with the
plague I don't care what people say
people did die but it there's nothing
compared to what what's happening in the
place every other person right exactly
it's not it's it's not even you know
it's 1% of the population it's not
through deep 30% or 50% of the
population yeah and so that is true and
then the the level of inequality is also
nothing to do with socio-economic
inequality than what we would have seen
in the in the Middle Ages and so on the
one hand everything is very everything
nothing is as intense but it just seems
very intense because of our media
apparatuses and our social media
apparatus is and you know I had to like
I yesterday I'm like I need to get off
Twitter because it was gonna drive me
crazy
the girls gonna completely drive me
insane it was poor me feels I feel like
I was being pulled in all these
different directions getting angry for
both sides getting angry this side that
side and then thinking okay no I need to
stop or else I'm just gonna I'm gonna
lose my mind yeah I dumped my Twitter at
the new year yeah and it was honestly it
was the best thing that I could have
done for my mental health I cannot
imagine with the stresses that are on
everybody right now
if I were on Twitter I might have a
breakdown I mean it's already I've I've
had so I've had a series of dreams
during this whole thing I had a dream
before the pandemic about the pandemic
mm-hmm
directly I mean it had to do with waves
and you know the elderly and I mean
everything was just like clockwork and
I've been watching it play out exactly
like my dream but I you know I've also
how did you dream finished vesper how
did it finish let me to tell you I'll
tell you the dream it's go for because
we need a prophet right now okay well um
okay so I was
on a back patio which doesn't it's my
dream house my fictional house right
sitting on a back patio and I noticed
this window box and it's full of these
spring flowers like huge azaleas and
daffodils and stuff and I I thought it
was the middle of winter but all of a
sudden its spring and it's this
abundance of spring so I go and I stick
my face in the flowers and I'm like
awesome a zhing spring is emerging it's
it's so incredible and then I go and
take a seat on the patio and I noticed
that next to my hat was a little beyond
my house is a river that I never knew
was there before oh how interesting
there's there's a river and I notice the
river starting to rise and I thought oh
gosh I think it's gonna flood instead of
flooding it turns into a tidal wave and
it crashes over the patio and it's
saltwater from a river
mm-hmm and it's bitter you know and but
it doesn't ever get into the house it
tumbles the patio furniture around you
know my mother and father-in-law were
there with me we kind of got knocked off
our feet a little bit but then it
receded we picked up the furniture again
and I looked over and I noticed that
those flowers that had been so abundant
there a minute before we're completely
gone as if they had never existed mm-hmm
right
no sooner did we kind of dust ourselves
off then a second wave comes yeah and
this wave was not as severe as the first
one but it still it came at you know
flooded the patio and this time it did
get a little bit into the kitchen where
my father-in-law was cooking something
and then I woke up and I told my husband
about it at the time and I said what do
you think this means because we we
really do believe in dreams and we've
been we've made major life decisions
based on dreams we've had and it's been
the right thing kind of when you know
it's that kind of dream you know yeah
and he had some thoughts about it for
himself and I thought I don't think
that's really what it means but I kind
of put it down for a while
and right when lockdown happened so I
think that was in January sometimes that
I had that dream
and March you know 12th or 13th comes
around because the lockdown starts and
my kids go to out of school and I'm
standing there doing the dishes and I
thought of that scripture that says that
the Lord doesn't do anything without
telling his prophets something like that
you know and I I just kind of prayed I
was like God why didn't you tell anybody
but this was gonna happen and he goes I
gave you a dream remember that dream I
gave you that was that you know so I was
like oh okay and I haven't gone around
like trumpeting it or anything like that
but it's been very instructive to me to
kind of keep me calm and level mm-hmm
know to say okay well this is what I can
expect and so far it's played out
exactly like that you know I think the
spring flowers had to do with the
economy you know things like that anyway
so but at the same time that I've been
feeling this sense of calm and you know
things playing out as they are going to
play out I found myself with like an
enormous amount of anxiety and I don't
suffer from anxiety or depression but
I've had a couple of anxiety attacks in
the stores some of it related to wearing
the mask yeah you can't breathe yeah not
only that but but you can't see people's
expressions yeah and that's that is just
deeply anti-human hmm you know to not be
able to see anybody's expression or read
their demeanor that's that's very deeply
like wounding to the psyche of the
populace you know what I mean so anyway
yeah so for the people who are watching
maybe we can decode some of the elements
of your dreams so that they or you can
understand it yes give me a symbolic
well right so you're you're you're sorry
the first thing is of course the the
idea of the of the water you know and
it's important that the water is salty
because the salty water is different
from fresh water and so you have this
river an extra house but it ends up
being ends up being salty bitter
like you said and so bitter waters in
the Bible is exactly that it's the
waters of chaos it's the waters that you
can't use really that's why it's a
sometimes I tell people salt waters it's
an image of chaos it's not arbitrary
it's it's the image of chaos because you
can't drink it it's not it's not it's
not it's not palatable for the human
person right it's a waste it's just this
chaos and so the obviously the wave
coming in it's it's interesting that so
then your house ended up playing the
role of a little arc which is which mass
which makes sense because that's what an
house is in a way that's what the ark
was as well it was like the preservation
of of square possibility right of
structure within a kind of uprising
chaos right um and so the fact that the
the way didn't get in it just it's a
very good sign you know like she said so
he destroyed the fruits but he didn't
destroy the structure exactly and let me
just interject here for a second
the only thing that it it did affect
were the temporary structures right the
patio the patio furniture which isn't
even real furniture right that's also
it's also the the idea of a patio or the
idea of a patio report or something like
that it really is this notion of it's
kind of like the extension of structure
into the outside but it's it's a
marginal extension right yes it's kind
of the effect of the structure but it's
not it's not the house it's not where
you you don't go there to be safe you
want you you kind of extend yourself out
into the natural world and so the idea
of the of the flowers and of the patio
you know it has to do with the fruits of
of the structure so it's good to see
that it's good to think because I also
you know when I have the same feeling of
when the the pandemic kid I had the same
feeling because at first I thought I was
getting ready I thought okay this is
gonna be massive I'm gonna lose my
commissions people are going to stop
supporting me on patreon I'm gonna lose
like basically I was expecting my
revenue to massively go down because of
the pandemic and then
and I was like okay interesting I mean
obviously some people who probably
struggle financially kind of went away
and some people put off their
commissions for later but you know it
didn't end up having a massive effect on
on the like the basic frame of my life
rom but for sure in terms of in terms of
the fruits of civilization that's for
sure that it definitely is having a
major effect and it had a major effect
on people's mental health that is for
certain yes yes I mean I've seen I've
been really surprised in the past few
weeks to around me to encounter suicide
suicide of people friends like a lot of
suicide either directly or in people who
know other people um and also people
mental breakdowns like yes real mental
people who just go crazy and leave for
three days I know and live in their car
because can't deal with it you know a
lot of that stuff going on yeah yeah I
mean I like I said I don't struggle with
mental illness thank God but I felt
myself you know praying at the edges and
you know one of the anxiety attacks that
I had was I was in target you know and
I'm walking around thinking to myself
people are you could feel it palpably
like people were so on the edge mentally
that I thought it's really surprising
that somebody hasn't cracked by now and
there there haven't been like several
mass shootings well this was three days
before the riots started so ya call that
prescient or call back you know reading
the writing on the wall
of what was kept what was happening but
yeah I mean I know a few people who had
expressed that they were having suicidal
thoughts and these weren't it wasn't
because they had lost jobs no it's more
than that it's it's more of a kind of a
weird breakdown of everything and uh and
the social isolation yeah it's more like
you said it's more than just economic
it's it's actually has to do with the
very like the fear and the very idea of
self isolating and you
we started now seeing some friends just
in the past few weeks and oh my goodness
I mean then you realize just how much
you need to be with people like yeah you
know because when you're you're just
living your life and you see friends and
you live your life you go to church you
do this you don't realize just how much
you need it in order to stay sane but
when it goes away then ya feel the
difference yeah and I was thinking about
you too because I'm reading the book
sacred pathways by Gary Thomas and he
talks about you know different people
having different spiritual personalities
let's say right so you have the The
Naturalist who really finds God in
nature and you know whatever and and the
traditionalist
who finds God through the you know the
smells and bells let's say and then
somebody like me who's more of a sense
eight you know I really encounter God
through the tangible making of things
and but also a little bit of a
traditionalist in that sense so I was
thinking about you at one point during
the quarantine in thinking about church
and we haven't really been able to like
we moved to where we live now like three
years ago and we haven't been able to
settle into a church and one of them
that we did visit was in an Orthodox
Church in my area and so I was wondering
like without like it is so communal the
Orthodox experience and so sensory that
if that were my normal expression I'd
really just be hurting for that right
now so I was wondering like how how are
you functioning in your church community
without do you have how do you do online
shirt oh yeah yeah they do they do I was
really I was really involved during the
time just before Easter like during Holy
Week and leading up to Easter I was very
very involved but it's just very
difficult oh I just find it very
difficult and and alienating and so to
be honest I I've gone to a few services
since since pasca but not a lot because
it's just so and we're not taking
communion and so
it's just very odd the whole thing is
very odd and and so I really hope that
this is going to end soon but just like
in the u.s. I I guess here in Quebec
religious services are way down on the
line of priority they don't consider
them important at all so so I don't know
how it's gonna and everybody is trying
to be a good Christian and obey the law
and to be you know to be respectful of
the authorities but it's it's pushing
the limits yeah well I will see how it
will see how it plays out we haven't yet
nothing has we haven't had been having
services at all even online or yeah they
have online services it's like what
exactly is that now
yeah with it without the communal aspect
of it then it's it's just um no it
doesn't make sense I wonder do you think
that at some point people are started
gonna start having clandestine masses
masses I think they probably already are
maybe no one has told me I'm sure the
clergy are we know with people that are
very very close to them and so I just
haven't necessarily been in the loop
maybe and Dubai might be a little far
from where I am even if there is so so
getting back to sort of the symbolic
nature of all this right like if you if
you deconstruct the church gathering
right where the communal Gathering the
ability to be together what do you think
that does to us
what does what's going on right now it
does exactly that so one of the things
that happened you know and is that the
the quarantine the quarantines took away
all the places where people were able to
one come together because let's say we
took away churches but those that aren't
religious they still had things like
restaurants things like coffee shops or
sports as well where the place of
identity and and Communion and so they
took away that then they took away also
the the sports is important I know that
people would think it's secondary but
for me I don't care about sports I'm not
interested in sports but for most for a
lot of people sports are a a few a place
to fuel your aggressive tendencies you
you put in your aggression into your
team and your team defeating other teams
then therefore it sublimates your your
aggression you know yeah and and it's
been like this forever right it's right
that's in a part with the gladiators
before you know right sublimate your
your aggression and so and then express
a catharsis yes because it's a communal
catharsis of violence right is really
would but it ends up being and and you
can criticizes all you want but if you
take it away then you end up with what
we've got now and so you end up with a
pseudo religious actions where people
are using all religious tropes right
tropes of scapegoating tropes of
catharsis tropes of violence of
contrition all the tropes that I'm
finding in religion are now the only
place where it is permitted yes this is
crazy the only place where it is
permitted is in these in these protests
and so in in all over the United States
you have the situation where the
authorities are telling people you still
need to to self isolate you still you
can't go to church you can't go to
restaurants you can't do all any of this
but but you can ban protests and yeah
I'm sure it almost like you should go
these things so it's almost you know I
hate be looking like a conspiracy
theorist but it looks like all of
people's all of people's religious drive
is being fueled into this thing and then
people are going along with it because
they need to vent that themselves and I
don't think that that sounds
conspiratorial at all I think that's
natural human tendency to want to fill
fill any vacuum right the politicians
want to fill the power vacuum you know
like you're saying people want to fill
the religious vacuum so I I went to a
protest in New York last week to stand
with some friends
and it was my first time out of my town
in four months but I'm a native New
Yorker you know so going back to my city
was really meaningful to me but I also
felt kind of alienated from it so and I
haven't spoken about this publicly
because I am in a posture of listening
right now I'm not well one thing's for
sure I'm not going to say other people's
words hmm I'm not going to say other
people's words until I fully understand
them and then at at such point if I feel
that they're my words too then I will
say them but I'm anyway I'll get there
so I caught up with you know walked into
the area where the protest was happening
and this was a rally that was going to
turn into a march and it was peaceful it
was not there's no writing
however riots had just happened that the
night before so I walk into the crowd I
enter the crowd and immediately I was
struck with the sense that I was in this
kind of movie type caricature of a
Catholic Mass and I couldn't there was
no there's in Foley Square where this
rally was taking place there is a
monument and I thought okay surely
somebody must be up there on the
monument kind of directing this right
but I couldn't hear any there was no PA
system or anything like that it seemed
to be completely decentralized but out
of the crowd would suddenly erupt this
chant you know no justice no peace or F
Trump or whatever it was you know and
but it was like plug it in say the
phrase unplug it was eerie it was very
creepy actually
and then the next cue was everyone's
fists went up unplug it's over the next
cue was everybody kneeled and I thought
this is weird just this is a religion
this is totally enacting a religious
right and
just like if you're a cradle Catholic or
whatever and you you don't even meet you
don't even need to be fully conscious of
what the priest is saying you just
intuitively know when to sits down and
kneel when to say the Our Father when to
you know that's what this was like and
what really struck me Jonathan was that
this rally in particular was I would say
in the end 85 percent white people and I
I don't know what to make of that
you don't know what to make of the fact
that happening know that it's that it is
it seems to me to be driven by white
people yeah at least in my in my
experience yeah and that's brought up
questions for me of a lie ship like the
definition of a lie and the meaning
really the meaning of the word a lie
I've been trying to sit with that and
deconstruct it and it seems to me that
an ally is somebody who's across is on
the other side of a border from you
right is across the ocean from you who
you you you make a mutual agreement to
come to each other's defense right
that's not a friend though like that's
not an intimate relationship you know
and I think that the term of a lie has
come to stand in for like a like a
believed intimacy that isn't really
there you know what I'm saying one of
the it's one of the problems is one of
the problems that day that the people in
that protest like these 85 percent white
people the problem that they have is
that they have to enact their their
their narrative they have to enact it
and let's say yeah so the did upper
class the upper class
rule white guessin right yes they they
have embraced the emancipatory narrative
right because that's our narrative like
the the emancipatory narrative of the
French Revolution of the revolution the
revolution idea the idea of you know the
underdog coming up and and you know
rising up and removing the removing the
the people above them and so this is not
just it's not just a racial thing right
now its rights happening in a with a
racial overtones but it's not it's
feminism it's yeah it's uh it's you know
it's it's basically like a kind of
communist ID ideal let's say of the
lower classes coming up and taking and
taking power and so they they have fully
accepted that narrative yet they're the
rich they're the elites okay they
interact their narrative they have to
flagellate dad to sell flagellate yes
it's the only way to it's the only way
for their narrative to actually to
actually make sense right yeah they give
up their power which they're not going
to do yeah or they just flagellate in
public in order to to signal that they
are that they agree with this narrative
but that they're not going to give their
houses to a black family you like that's
not gonna happen right or okay I'll get
there so growing up in New York is a
very very very different experience than
transplanting to New York from the
Midwest and I'm gonna I'm gonna make
people angry by saying this okay but
this is what I do there there's there's
a certain type of person who moves to
New York who's whose daddy pays full
tuition to NYU or whatever school
Columbia a certain type of person who
comes from the suburbs and deeply
resents their conservative upbringing or
what have you or feels deeply guilty
that their parents were both doctors or
something like that
comes to New York to try to kind of shed
all of that and like live this kind of
authentic experience you know what I
mean and I've been encountering more and
more people like that over the years and
I find it deeply alienating I because
what they don't understand that they're
doing is pushing out communities that
have been there for generations some of
those communities you know that I grew
up in and and convincing themselves that
they are allies or speaking for people
who they may have met somebody from that
community when they're for the first
time when they're 25 mm-hmm you know and
so the the thought that people would do
this and enact not just I'm not going to
give up my house for a black person but
I'm actually going to take a brick and
put it through the window of the black
business and for the community if you
want to know why Twitter was driving me
crazy
it was watching those those punk Antipa
kids destroying that community like I
just it just made me so angry you know I
was like I so sorry that's one of the
reasons why I Twitter was there any
crazy was just watch that happen and to
thank again you're doing that in the
news like what yeah
you're insane right right and so and so
isn't that in a sense what an ally would
do in that like let's take it from a
military perspective right an ally would
come and drop bombs in a country that
they may be trying to liberate yeah yeah
yeah yeah right that's that's a good
analogy that's what the US has done in
the Middle East you know to liberate
countries they destroy them right you
look at Syria my goodness yeah Damascus
is has been completely leveled so yeah
no I I agree I agree with your ear
analysis and I but it's there's a
blindness
because it's ideological the thing about
that's a problem with with the thing
about the problem with symbolism and
it's a problem with also with the way
that I think is that the when you're
dealing with symbolism we're dealing
with categories with which coagulate
right so you have characteristics which
coagulate into categories and you notice
them but you have to also be careful of
its effects yes you know because what
happens in when you idealize these idea
it's like I'm an ally of black people
but that there are no there is no black
people you only encounter actual
individuals you only encounter
individuals there is no like you can't
encounter the category you only
encounter people and so when people get
attached it's like you know it's like
that idea of the of the common man or
the working man and there's an amazing
one of my favorite scenes in movies is
in the Cohens brother movie what's the
name of the the Barton Fink where Barton
Fink is like is a writer who writes
plays about the common man and he's
talking to a like a Salesman and he's
telling him about the common man and the
common man the sales like yeah I could
tell you some stories and he's like yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and this is exactly what's happening
with narratives about the working class
right yeah yeah although it's only
hilarious because that a lot of the rich
elite types they you would hate the
working class they do hate the working
class they do because the problem with
the working class a lot of the working
class guys are just regular guys they'll
say things which don't at all
politically correct all the time and so
you on the one hand you want you want to
defend them but on their if you actually
met someone who's like that you would
you would see only their faults because
it right Christine political correct
rain so how do you how do you deal with
that right and the working class is not
just people of color and the working
class is not just white people it's
everybody it's most people most people
are working class yeah it's just so
disconnected
reality yeah for sure that's definitely
one of the reasons why we're seeing it
happened but I think understanding this
can really help you understand why it
has to be it has to be symbolizing
religious patterns and use as you know
that people will act out these things
it's the same thing like I hate to say
it but it's the same thing with
recycling like recycling is also taken
on a religious overtone because all
these people who are living like kings
and queens which it's like I'm not even
gonna criticize that but then at the
same time they think that we're
destroying the environment so how do you
do it how do you do it well you need to
have a way to to atone for your sins and
so you have to recycle like if you don't
recycle
then you're evil because I it's not that
I'm evil if those that don't recycle
that are evil yeah so but then it
doesn't make does it really make a
difference like our like here in Quebec
I have a one of my family members he's
really into in construction and works in
this in that world and he says you know
half those recycle recycling trucks they
just go to the dump they just go
straight to the dump and so it ends up
being just a a kind of gesture of
atonement yeah anyways so speaking of
performance art what happened my friend
Steven Roach says that you know um you
know that liturgy is performance art you
know that we are it's it's deeply
important that we reenact you know these
things well it matters what you reenact
this pose but um so what do you think
okay because I just started this podcast
about artistic thinking and I'm trying
to give people an alternative to the
political worldview kind of similar what
you're doing in terms of the symbolic
world but I want to help people to to
get in touch with their own critical
thinking capacities right as coming from
specifically from the point of view of
an artist right so as a fellow artist
what
you think that we have to offer in this
moment well the best things I think that
artists have to offer is that their
capacity to understand that the world
needs image and narrative like that the
world manifests itself through image and
story and so we understand that because
we experience it because when you're
trying to draw something you have to
make decisions about what you're going
to leave out and what you're going to
put in because the world is too big to
complicate it and it's the same with a
story when you're telling a story you
you know that you know that there is no
neutrality in our perception that our
perception is qualified by narrative and
an image you have to you have to decide
which elements which which events are
you going to choose to put together in
order to tell a story and so I think
that because of that if we are aware of
that we we have a we're almost like
magicians we have a magical power and if
we understand it then we can we can
probably use our magical power for good
and not also also understand that it's
not arbitrary and it and it does matter
the stories we tell do matter and so you
know a lot of you know it's because you
can be a magician you can also you can
tell twisted stories to to gain very
very pointed attention because it works
right just like passions are very
pointed and will get your attention
then stories that are extremely pointed
and twisted will also get attention but
I think that as artists who want to kind
of be part of a healing process or help
the world return to logos or return to
the the idea of of God and creation
meeting somehow then we have to be
attentive to the story we retell and we
can tell we can change the world with
our stories yeah you know like I keep
telling people about no let's say we as
20th century Christians I say we have we
have tokine and lord of the rings and
what's interesting about him is that his
is the imagination structure imaginal
structure of our of the modern world
it's the Lord of the Rings yeah all the
video games all the comic books all the
all the fantasy novels all of this all
Harry Potter all of it could not exist
without the the pattern that token gave
the 20th century and so he told the
story that was so big that it sunk and
and and and one of the ways you know
that it is that powerful is that elites
don't like it the Elysa really don't
like Lord of the Rings they think it's a
it's a badly written you know that it's
kind of amateurish or whatever and
that's even better it's like yeah yeah
yeah just like they thought scripture
was written in bad Greek you know it's
like that's fine that's fine that's that
those that are able to connect the
highest stories with the lowest let's
say manifestations they're the ones who
win in the end because they they sink
into the into the pattern of reality and
so I think that that's what the power we
have we really have that power and we
can see in the 20th century those that
have used that power
I would say for evil or to twist and to
to make the problem worse but there are
also a few shining examples of people
that that are participating in the in
the healing so that's what we should I
think that's what we should be doing
yeah yeah agreed
I think um I think that artists have
been I mean artists have always had a
political bent of course but I think
what we've seen in maybe the last couple
decades is that artists have really been
co-opted by the political worldview like
to an extreme degree but there are some
of us outliers you know who are still
staying connected to that narrative
structure and I like what you say often
about that you know that Jesus or the
logos like fills the whole narrative
structure the whole hierarchy from top
to bottom you know and that you can
never get you can never exhaust that you
know you never get away from that and
those of us that are stay
connect to whether were Christians or
not but to that concept that's just such
a deeply artistic way to see the world
and I think it's very hopeful yeah I
think so too
I think there's one little dream that I
had last night that I wanted to share
with you and get your okay so one of the
things that I noticed in the protests
that I attended was that there was no
music and right so as much as it was
following this very kind of religious
structure there was no music and even
the I would even go so far as to say
there was very little creativity so the
signs all said the same thing the signs
were just the usual slogans there
weren't I'm familiar with protests this
is not my first rodeo you know and and I
followed I I'm a Martin Luther King girl
like dyed-in-the-wool you know so
protest is not new to me
signage marches these are not new things
in my life so when I have been two
previous protests I'm so used to the
artists really coming forth and taking
the opportunity to get creative with
their signage now I understand that this
is all very like sudden and raw and so
we haven't had the time to process and
come up with you know really creative
like slogans and things like that but I
just really was struck by it seemed
devoid of a spirit of creativity to me
right okay so that's the backdrop so
I've been thinking a lot about like what
made the civil rights movements so
powerful and so successful in its aims
at the time and one of those things was
music whether it's you know the
spirituals that would be sung during
protests or whether it was you know
protest songwriters like Bob Dylan you
know or Woody Guthrie or Odetta you know
people singing these songs of protest
and you can buy records so saw
of protest from the 60s and stuff right
um I've been asking myself how is that
going to emerge again like what is the
song of this current movement is there
one okay so that's the backdrop so last
night I had this very brief dream where
I was at some kind of like Church dinner
or conference dinner or something and
people were milling around socializing
it didn't have any real form and I sat
down at a keyboard and I started to play
this song this protest song called lift
every voice and sing and it's sometimes
called the black national anthem and
it's a song that I grew up with a song
that we sang in school and I was trying
to figure out the you know I'm playing
the music for it but I couldn't remember
the words so there's somebody sitting
next to me on the piano bench and I turn
to him and it's dr. Martin Luther King
and I turned to him and I said oh do you
remember the words to the song and he
didn't say anything he just sort of it's
hard to describe it he kind of gestured
with his presence to the fact that I had
a stack of books in my hand and at the
bottom of this stack of books was the
book of poetry lift every voice and sing
and so I opened the book and I put it up
on the piano stand and instead of having
the words listed you know on one page
like that would make it easy to be able
to sing it at the piano the words were
running at the bottom of every page of
the book so you'd have to keep turning
the page and turning the page to get all
the lyrics and then I woke up okay so
Jonathan pezzo which I think it means I
don't know I'd have to think about it
it's not uh it's not obvious it's not
obvious at all right in terms of what
you're saying yeah hmm I don't think
about it because I nothing comes to
nothing comes to mind one of the things
though that I might want to say in terms
of the fact
difference between the civil rights
movement and and now is it it is very
different because in the civil rights
movement there was active opposition to
the goal the protest
whereas today I don't I understand the
anger of the moment because it was a
horrifying thing to see you want
horrifying to watch that and I can only
understand it but the the goal I don't
see anybody opposing it like I don't see
resistance I don't see the authorities
saying no we're gonna keep you down
like all right so it's it seems to me it
seems different than trying to remove
segregation and Jim Crow rules it I
don't totally so I don't understand
there isn't at all a sense massive
corporations are all coming in favor all
the levels of government even though
people hate Trump Trump came right away
and said this guy should be should be
arrested and everybody everybody agrees
that what happened is horrible and that
and he has been and the and the police
officer has been right and his wife left
him and and the whole his whole world is
over right and so and so and so it's
very different because it doesn't then
look like the same kind of protest we
saw before it really does look more like
a kind of religious atonement of some
kind some kind of massive religious
atonement for something and so it's I
don't know I just find a different and
that might also be why we don't we're
not going to find music that is let's
say specific of this this protest
because our whole culture is that I
think our whole culture is aesthetically
in tune with what the people want like
this idea of racial equality of of the
value of black culture of the value and
so I don't I mean I there are
exceptions but sure and there are all
but I mean in terms of a thrust its it
that seems to be the the culture and so
I and so I struggle to see how there
could be some kind of let's say graffiti
graffiti rebellious art that could be
there that hasn't already been expressed
right right it's like Public Enemy made
millions of dollars selling their albums
and that was in the 80s and that was a
long time ago and Kendrick Lamar is a
Multi multi multi-millionaire and and
the people and and his movies are and
Marta his music is in Marvel movies
right so the images that would maybe
represent this movement are not marginal
anymore yeah I wonder if the work that
you're doing and to some extent the work
that I'm doing is actually the work of
rebellion you mean you know what I mean
the I mean doing work from the work from
meta-narratives like three and and
figurative work and I wonder if that is
that is the rebellion well I I tend to
think that I mean I tend to think that a
restoring restoring a fuller world view
yes is in a way as the is the most it's
both the most it's both an act of
restoring a form of order but also
restoring the possibility of
transgression you know I always tell
people it's like I understand the margin
better than you guys do yeah and I
understand it I understand its value and
its role and I talk about it all the
time yeah but I also understand the
problem with the margin and the
difficulties that are there just like I
understand the problem and the the the
value of authority and so I think that
restoring a more fuller vision of the
world can maybe help us but
you know honestly it might be too late
that's as I say that but I mean III
right now I'm thinking a remnant it will
be enough you know but I don't see I
don't see massive I don't see it having
a massive effect at least not at this
time
yeah yeah I'm I think your work on the
margins has really helped me to
understand
I mean I've I've never left the margins
I've lived on the margins my whole life
and I don't there's nowhere that I fit
I'm politically homeless and all of that
but I said in one of my episodes
recently it's like living always living
in the lobby and never the sanctuary but
I have a deep connection to the
sanctuary and I have a deep connection
to the parking lot you know but I'm in
the lobby yeah yeah but but there's a
place there's a deeply important place
for the margin and for the lobby and for
the the narthex you know for the ability
to people for people to pass through you
to one side or the other and I've come
to very deeply appreciate that that that
is who I've been made to be and who I'm
called to be as an artist as a Christian
because the other the other structure
that lives in the margin is a bridge
yeah and hey I welcome that totally
that's great that's great well we have
we've been going for a while I think I
think this is a good place to stop I
think so yeah I wish you the best with
your book and I've started I started
reading it I haven't finished but I but
I definitely kind of dove in and so I'm
looking forward to seeing to sing to
learning more about it and I wish you
the best maybe when it comes out and
everything we could have another
conversation Oh that'd be great and
hopefully the world may have taken a
deep breath by then yeah let's hope yeah
all right vapor is good to talk to you
YouTube thanks janitor right okay